[Applause]
so there's oscar talk around this new
movie are you excited or does that make
you nervous do you don't want to talk
about it nervous i'm just like if it
happens great if it doesn't i have a
really great career i've gotten to work
with jane campion is like getting an
oscar no he's just working with her is
like was one of my my dreams in life
yeah um who do you play you want to talk
about your character yeah i play rose
she's a widow um she runs an inn
it's the 1920s in montana and rose looks
sad rose
rose doesn't look crap
i marry my real life partner jesse in
the film and i move into this massive
montana ranch and um his brother starts
to gaslight me and he doesn't want me in
the house so he basically
psychologically tries to torture me
into
um like going a little mentally crazy
wow yeah and then i turned to alcoholism
to cope and even be in the home
how
that sounds horrible all of that and and
also it must be kind of fun to play
though as a character i don't know she's
kind of like she's a dragon play yeah
it's just kind of a drag you get a lot
of old feelings of feeling bad about
yourself like going back into my own
history of times when i felt like really
insecure or bad about myself or like
someone else was trying to control me
somehow or yeah just really things that
you deal with mostly as like i would
hope like
as a young person just been navigating
hopefully you've worked together yeah
exactly so
so for me
that's hard to revisit that emotion
though just yeah i mean it's important
for this role but not a fun place to
live in i definitely felt more insecure
while making the project than i had in a
long time just in my own brain yeah that
sounds emotionally exhausting um i am so
intrigued to see this okay you just you
set it up nicely i'm like i'm happy and
then it says
so your character you said is an
alcoholic right so if he turns to
alcoholism to cope with or alcohol
alcohol to deal with even being in the
home
yeah yeah yeah is there a secret to
playing a drunk on camera i actually do
have one very good trick that alice and
janie taught me um
on drop dead gorgeous i was supposed to
be kind of out of it oh my god i love
drop dead gorgeous oh thank you i love
that i was gonna bring it up but it's
like one of my favorite things okay keep
going okay so uh she taught me to spin
around in a circle a bunch so a lot of
times when i come out it's it works a
lot of times when i'd like come out of
the house like screaming for my child
i'd have to be a little stumbly so i'd
stand up you want to do it i do i do i'm
like wait if you're like so close your
eyes oh shoot okay we're rolling okay
we're rolling we're rolling we're
rolling how many times action okay all
right get out there claire come here
like you feel a little fluffy right yeah
you need a hand exactly okay that's
that's and that's that's a really good
that's a good that's a good trick also
if you have a headache
[Applause]
so much of this movie is about
self-worth
and what were some of the steps you took
to work on your own self-worth because i
feel like you touched on this a bit just
because when we were younger
it was always like it was it's easier to
be were you more like appeasing to
others like what they wanted and because
you mentioned you said like if you were
in situations where somebody might have
been controlling i feel like i
experienced that when i was younger as
well i mean don't i feel like when
people are in power if they don't handle
power well they take it out on younger
people especially young talented people
and they want to like control that or
like a boyfriend sees or you know it's
just unhealthy people throwing their
crap at you you know what i mean so
projection that's all it is and so i've
definitely had i've had things like that
happen in my life and you know then you
realize oh actually i want to go out
with someone who's really nice to me i
know what i mean like a nice person oh
weird yeah i want someone to treat me
nice and like yeah i love the role
though i think a lot of people
unfortunately will relate to that
environment like a lot of people have
been there before in work or in like
relationships really anything it is
there's a yeah a serious thing happening
in the film where he'll just
you know we have the scene where i'm
playing piano and he he trumps me with
his artistry of playing this banjo
really beautifully playing the same
piece as me and it's like those things
that just those little things he just
like hurry topper yeah he just
like makes me feel
awful about myself and i'm but then
obviously
uh
rose is in a zone where it's like a
little thing like that can really make
her feel worthless and so she's she's in
a place of people-pleasing rose very
much so where she doesn't want to upset
the household and instead of just
talking to her you know husband about it
which you know it's difficult in that
time i think you know women were
probably expected to play a different
role yeah and so she keeps she swallows
a lot by the end of it do you feel
empowered or do you want to cry you i
think
rose is i think empowered by the end
okay she's at peace i think okay i'm so
excited okay then they eat the like evil
brother i will call him and it's
benedict cumberbatch is that who's
playing i love him he's amazing yeah
it's a great cast it's yeah yeah the
cast is amazing and um it's one of his
best performances in his career i think
and
cody who plays my son's incredible
um i keep wanting to talk about him but
i'm like i can't give that away but yeah
yeah he's yeah
yeah it's a jane campion movie for those
of you don't know she did the piano and
she's just like
one fabulous yeah directors out there ah
i'm so excited
[Music]